good morning believe nation today's
message is know what you want over to
you Lupe Fiasco I wake up every mood
espresso TV go know what you want I
always say that buy anything if my
number one piece of advice to anyone
trying to be in any industry is know
what you want you know whether it be the
most materialistic thing you want a
million dollars and a house and you know
or you want to be recognized as the best
of the best whatever you want ten
Grammys whatever just know what you want
you know and then you you know then
you'll know what paths to take to get
there I think everyone should know like
exactly what they want out of life out
of their job out of out of like their
training program because it gives you a
target so knowing what you want as
opposed to knowing what you think you
should want is also a big thing because
it relates to I guess finding your
passion if you're going after something
that you think you won that you really
don't want eventually you're going to
lose motivation you're going to stop
pursuing whatever that is so knowing
what you want like where you actually
want and picking something that you're
actually passionate about will help you
to be more successful just because
you're going to be
going after that thing with a lot more
motivation and for a lot longer than you
would if something like you didn't
really want yeah it's amazing how
effective goal setting can be you know
if you have a goal you want to
accomplish it you set a time line and
the target you're much more likely to
follow through and to start to execute
and I think too many entrepreneurs start
and they they just started and they
don't have a planet they don't instead
have a big vision they don't know quite
what they want and we just kind of
wandering aimlessly around and so as
much as you can get defined on what you
want it'll really help you get there
faster so the question today today is
what do you want so thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and they'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press ok this pray so give me go